et à saint quentin en yvelines une
cinquantaine de médecins généralistes à
appliquer désormais des dépassements
pour exigence particulière du patient en
dehors des plages horaires de 9h à 17h
un mouvement qui s'apparente aux 35
heures en réponse au projet de loi de
santé que les médecins condamne on
écoute tout de suite le docteur équerre
médecin généraliste elle en cours nous
dit souvent que on aidé des salariés de
la sécurité sociale
on a dit ben si on est descendu de la
sécurité sociale à ce moment là on
travaille 35 heures c'est pour ça qu'on
va prendre par exemple un dépassement
pour exigence particulière mais qu'on ne
prend pas aux patients qui sont eux qui
ont la cmu ou le l'aide médicale d'état
ou l'assurance qu'on peut appeler un
terreau santé ou qui sont en accident de
travail
si le patient à une mutuelle et ben on
prendra on prendra 2 euros on peut
prendre 10 euros si c'est des gens dont
on sait qu'ils ont une très bonne
mutuelle voilà par exemple bon et les
gens qui n'ont pas de mutuelle c'est
plus rare mais c'est vrai que des
chômeurs peuvent très bien de perdre
deux mutuelles et ben on le reprendra
rien évidemment et